I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark I love my eyes I
didn't miss anything
what what
[Music]
Battlefield Earth never in my life did I
ever want to say that title in a video
on my channel but I started a segment
entitled hilarious Adira views in which
I talk about films that are such
atrocities they are hilarious and so
it's my own fault if you guys follow me
on Twitter you would have seen that over
the past few days I have actually been
attempting to watch Battlefield Earth in
its entirety it took me two days over
the course of like three to four
sittings to finish this movie I think
I've watched about 17 minutes of it
before I said no can't take it anymore
off later that day I watch about another
20 minutes of it and I couldn't take it
anymore and to turn it off again this is
a true story I actually sat down with my
fiancee and she encouraged me to finish
it like she had to give me like Yoda
advice she was like it will be fine dude
do not there is no try you told them you
do it I was like I know honey I'm trying
but thankfully I finished the film took
about 10 pages of notes and Here I am to
talk about one of the worst films ever
made now you may be thinking to yourself
Chris how is this a hilarious 'ti it's
so bad you had such a hard time watching
it isn't it supposed to be entertaining
if you think it's a hilarious 'ti and I
wanna see Battlefield Earth inhabits a
different section of the hilarious 'ti
review it's a film that as you watch it
you begin to be in such awe the fact
that it actually exists on this earth
and it just becomes so funny when you
actually imagine someone filming the
damn thing and saying yeah that's the
shot I like we'll use that one
nevertheless a quick backstory about
this film John Travolta really wanted to
make this film because he is a
Scientologist and the book is written by
the founder of Scientology this man
wanted John Travolta to make this movie
for many years he wanted the film to be
in the vein of Star Wars and John
Travolta it was like a passion project
you just wanted to be made so bad the
movie opens and it says Battlefield
Earth a saga of the year 3000 it's
almost like they decided okay we're not
gonna use that subtitle they just wanted
to call it Battlefield Earth they had
already rendered the title screen so
they couldn't go back and change it
because that cost money something these
filmmakers clearly didn't have much of
and the movie is called Battlefield
Earth but in my opinion it should just
be called evil laughter the movie
because that's all this movie is it's a
whole bunch of scenes in which it ends
with somebody going ha ha ha
haha now before I get into talking about
what actually happens in this movie I
feel the need to inform you that
basically every shot in this film is at
a Dutch angle slanted a 45 degree angle
however you want to call it every single
shot almost in this film is like that if
you saw Thor and thought there was too
much of that in there
go watch Battlefield Earth Thor is gonna
be like a drop in the bucket compared to
Battlefield Earth every single shot in
this film looks so incredibly ugly that
it just makes your eyes bleed movie
opens with Barry Pepper and he's sliding
down a hill on a horse or a stuntman is
anyway he returns to his small little
village in which mankind is just almost
nearly extinct we learned that because
of a quick little sentence that pops up
on the screen to explain it to us he
wasn't able to find any food or any
supplies of any kind he talks to this
girl that you immediately kind of guess
she's a girl friend is something I just
there's no there's nothing there's no
depth of any kind it's just a girl and
you're supposed to be like okay she's
she's a girl and he's a guy so they must
be together he gets very upset and
throws a rock or something into the air
with this horribly audio dub scream and
this horrific Allah badly framed shot
and let me get our first wipe yeah every
single scene this movie ends with a
white cut every one of them there's
maybe like one or two that dozen but
most of them just go boom
it was like they watch Star Wars and
we're like hey there's a lot of cool
wipes and transitions in that movie
let's just do that because that's why
Star Wars was good right cuz it had cool
transitions so he's in his cave with
some of his fellow men and they're all
scared of these demons these things that
are apparently outside that are keeping
them from venturing beyond their cave
and he sites to get up and do some sort
of intense dramatic display for his
fellow man in regards to this whole
thing about there being demons out there
has anyone here ever seen one a demon Oh
a monster oh please yeah I don't
understand the purpose of that but
that's just that's just the start okay
the more things happen so our hero Barry
Pepper whose name is Johnny by the way
like the most conventional hero name
ever for the year 3000 for a cave
dwelling man who's afraid of demons
outside his house his name's Johnny he
decides to venture out because he
doesn't believe all that stuff he wants
to go see what else is out there and
he's on his horse and everything and
just put this lame-o every set in this
movie or location looks like complete
shit he comes across these two guys who
are very hostile and I gotta say this
scene had me holding my sides doubled
over from laughing what I don't get
about this guy this guy who I'm gonna
call the monkey guy for the rest of this
review later in the film and throw it
even this scene he speaks perfect
English and yet he makes monkey noises
constantly it's crazy and you wonder why
the fucking aliens call him man animals
throughout the whole movie so these guys
are going on and on about the fact there
are gods everywhere you can see him
everywhere they've done things to people
they frozen people while they stand the
thing that confuses me is it took him
like not even a day to ride out there on
his horse and he's in awe of everything
he sees are you seriously telling me
that no one in that cave of people even
decided to venture out and look around
them
less than a day's ride extremely
abruptly this little green laser being
like wisps into one of the guys and he
just blows backwards and you see that
this dreadlocked alien creature is
shooting them with these little beams
they're like this big
honestly a CGI laser beam is one of the
easiest things for a CGI artist to
create I did it on fucking Microsoft
Paint when I was a teenager for one of
my stupid little Star Wars short films I
actually had little booboo I did it on
Microsoft Paint and they looked better
than these things in Battlefield Earth
so Johnny gets shot by one of these
beams and he blasts through all this
glass in this horrible slow-mo frame
rate matrix attempt to copy off the
matrix that's another thing I want to
talk about because movie came out in the
year 2000 it's very clear that
filmmakers saw the matrix while making
this movie and thought we need to rip
that off because that's all we have I'll
get to it more but there are so many
moments in this movie that just look
like they're tell me to copy off the
matrix especially with a slow motion but
the problem is the slow motion is so
poorly done you can tell the not every
scene it's in slow motion was meant to
be in slow motion when they filmed it
because they're not filming it at a
frame rate that makes slow motion look
good they're filming it at a normal
frame rate and then in post trying to
slow it down except it looks like
garbage because it wasn't filmed at a
frame rate that actually supports slow
motion so you can actually tell that
it's like they were watching the matrix
while filming Battlefield Earth and
we're like oh my gosh this is the next
big thing this is what we need to do and
so they slow mode like everything but it
looks like shit so Johnny gets
imprisoned in this ship and it gets
transported to Jamaica I'm calling it
Jamaica cuz everyone there has
dreadlocks and there's lots of drugs and
alcohol going around and quite a bit of
firearms that's that's racist okay so
Johnny kills one of them by screaming
[Music]
and then he tries to flee and as he's
running you can just see him like
flailing his arms like this I'm like who
fucking runs like that no one fucking
runs like that ever
sorry I'm seeing words I don't usually
say smoothly just movie
Johnny slips and falls and this is when
we meet John Travolta's character Turell
and he's wearing stilts
everyone in this movie who is an alien
wears stilts it's so obvious too because
the way they walk there's like earth oh
oh it's like oh my god where's stilts
right now I hope no one notices Soter
lie actually gives Johnny a gun he's
like here's a gun
just take it I don't know why and then
Johnny's like he just glares at everyone
he could have shot them all including
John Travolta the main villain he could
just shot him right there John Duvall
doesn't have some special shield or
something you could just shot him right
there there was no Scientology shield of
any kind it could have activated that
moment you could've just shot him but he
doesn't he just glares at him and
finally he decides to kill of course
some random little minion side character
and then he just gets in a headlock and
that's it worst hero ever and of course
they all laugh evilly
[Laughter]
so Travolta meets up with this movies
version of the Emperor from Return of
the Jedi and they have a quick little
discussion about how John Travolta is
gonna be transferring out of this place
soon then they want to blow up earth
afterwards and of course they have a
laugh about it
evilly let's exterminate the lot of them
oh you're too much but soon poor Johnny
learns that his transfer request was
declined and more evil laughter ensues
we've decided to keep you here for
another 50 cycles whatever the options
for renew with endless options for renew
with endless options for renew we
decided to keep you on for 50 cycles
with endless options for renewal endless
options for renewal endless options for
renewal till next scene we have John
Travolta at a bar and he's being served
to drink by a conehead so these guys are
called cyclos they hate humans they
refer to them as man animals and yet
they follow quite a bit of human customs
like having bars and getting drunk and
even speaking the English language
now that language thing is a little
confusing in this movie isn't it if
you've watched this movie you know what
I'm talking about sometimes they'll just
be speaking their Psychlo language and
then all of a sudden are speaking
English sometimes it mixes together and
then there are times when there are
subtitles on the screen it's like they
can't decide to let us know that it's
speaking English for fun or if they're
speaking syclo right now and we're just
hearing English it doesn't make any
sense nothing in this movie makes sense
half this movie is Travolta at a bar
drinking some sort of green fluid I'm
not kidding he's have said he's not
getting transferred and he gets so upset
with Forest Whitaker and he goes on this
rant about before you weren't even
learning how to spell your name I was
being trained to conquer galaxies it's
just amazing to me that this dialogue
was written you know and then performed
by a man who looks like that and filmed
by professionals who said that's the one
we're gonna put in the movie while you
were still learning how to spell your
name
I was being trained to conquer galaxies
the wickedly talented one and only until
it doesn't spell your name Adela that
does he yeah I went there so we finally
cut back to our hero who's imprisoned
and he's fighting for a green food while
he wears green clothes and people with
green eyes watch we get it green stuff
you like the look of green the green
filter for all these scenes we get it
the matrix happened the matrix was
awesome quit copying off of it please
Thanks now we get a couple of random
scenes in which the villains talk about
random bla bla bla crap in which they
are trying to get to a point a point
that progresses the plot I've seen this
done in really horrible movies where
they're like in this scene a character
needs to do this but we need to stretch
out the runtime so we'll just have them
talk about random stuff the whole time
right okay that's what we do they just
keep talking about stuff that actually
has absolutely nothing to do with the
plot at all
and then at the end John Travolta will
be like oh by the way it'd be nice if
man animals mind for us wouldn't it oh
you don't like that idea what I like it
a lot ha ha ha but seriously John
Travolta wants humans to learn how to
mine so they can find more gold if Lee
would you train them how to mine
[Laughter]
operating machinery and everyone just
doubts him instantly I'm like you guys
are currently living around the rubble
of mankind later in the film they go to
a library that is filled with mankind's
history they clearly never really got
too much into reading that they should
be able to realize that humans are
capable of doing shit and they just keep
doubting them all the time cuz they're
so stupid
worst villains ever so we see Johnny
marching with the other
prisoners and some random collapse of
some kind happens on a structure that
gives him a chance to escape and run
around in slow motion of course with
this horrible droning score in the
background and then he gets shot by a
sound effect we don't even see the beam
this time it's like they didn't even
take the time to animate this the Rabine
and the funny thing is that like
throughout this movie the humans are
always like we are worth something
these people are disrespecting us and
everything and then they just start
screaming like Apes and monkeys the
whole time and you're like no wonder
they call you man animals you idiots you
like fucking monkeys over there
seriously what'd they do I just homo is
oh oh oh
battlefield oh oh this next scene is so
nuts like I don't get it John Travolta
decides I think that like he thinks
Johnny is resourceful so he decides to
somehow transport him and two other
people to this icy Mountain to search
for food so that he can learn what
humans favorite food is so that he can
persuade them do things for him how is
this relevant I was this fucking do
anything like I just don't get it what
does that to do anything ah if he wants
to find out what humans favorite food
are you could just walk up and say what
do you want to eat I just turned to Bill
Cosby what do you want to you want to
chocolate cake do you want to chocolate
cake for breakfast chocolate cake milk
eggs
that's nutrition jell-o pudding pops Jim
I just went on the biggest tangent of a
Bill Cosby impression in my life I am
not editing that out I'm keeping it in
this video I do not care
but seriously I don't even understand
what the point of this scene is it just
cuts and all of a sudden he's like yeah
Steve been out there for three days
they've got to be hungry by now what
like we were just another scene they
somehow just teleport out there and all
of a sudden they've been out there for
three days on this icy Mountain they'd
eat anything and of course they'd find a
rat and so all these like rats that's
what they like yes
rats well feed the rats that will
persuade them to to do something because
we're evil but the scene ends in a great
way so at least there's that check this
out first off hitting his head on the
ceiling is amazing but then Forest
Whitaker's like slow-mo turns smile wipe
cut it's pretty amazing
but I don't understand why it's there
all of a sudden we have a scene that's
actually shot normally I don't get where
it came from but of course a ship comes
down and Johnny throws a stick at it
worst hero ever
so Travolta grabs Johnny and we're like
oh my gosh are we actually about to see
some menace some real villainy a scene
that actually makes John Travolta out to
be an actual villain no he's just gonna
leave the room well Johnny has some
machine teach him stuff about Psychlo
because clearly the way to deal with
your enemy is to educate them on
everything make them smarter and make
them better at everything that they
weren't good at before worst villains in
a movie Ville time so next basically
Johnny becomes the Rain Man of man
animals that's right he's drawn shapes
on the ground he's just pulling facts
out of his head he knows everything
facts are spurting all over the place
she learned something about molecular
biology this is the symbol for water so
this machine could teach molecular
biology but it can't teach the damn
cyclos what humans favorite foods are
again what was the toughest of the food
scene why did they have to be stranded
on an ice mountain for three days just
to eat a rat and drown
their favorite food is rap that's it
brother
so next in his continuing string to
educate his enemy on everything John
Travolta takes his character to a
library filled with books that have been
in the open air for 1,000 years of
course these books are in pretty good
shape and his cuts and dust on him yeah
that would never happen so all of a
sudden these group of forest freaks just
burst out of the forest and they're
basically the Ewoks of this film and you
can really just see all the ways they
were trying to copy off the Star Wars
throughout this movie for a second
Johnny gets the upper hand he has the
gun pointed directly at Travolta he's
sitting there with a gun pointed out I'm
in drool just like didn't you learn
anything about your species humans were
the only species ever to hunt animals
for sport so he knows about human
history about how we hunted animals for
sport think he'd know about how he
hunted animals for food too and that our
favorite food isn't rats I'm gonna keep
pointing back to that because that is
the dumbest scene in his movie nothing
in that scene makes sense nothing about
it makes sense nothing nothing in that
scene Rickson not a thing
me and my men are with you in like two
seconds Johnny convinces everyone to
fight against the cyclos including these
forest freaks we met exactly 1 minute
ago we know nothing about these people
they just burst out of the woods they're
like hey we're here in the movie too
what do you guys want to do hey let's go
war okay let's do it
oh oh who are you I hope fucking know
where you are let's be in a war together
okay let's do it that's the scene that's
the scene that is the see pictures
you're like hey who are you I don't know
who you are let's do it let's go then he
gives the gun back to John Travolta he
just gives it to him he does like this
cheesy flip like I can determine it
gives it back resulting in another man
getting his head blown off by Turrell
and he sees his girlfriend's been
captured the girlfriend we met for
one minute in the beginning of the movie
worst hero ever so next we have a scene
in which John Travolta once again is
kind of getting drunk at a bar because
that's all he does is lounge around at a
bar and drink baby cycle on a straight
diet of her Bango
what during this portion of the movie
actually paused it and I said to myself
this entire movie is about John
Travolta's character trying to get
knowest that's it he's just wants
attention his big sinister scam is he
wants people to look at him that's it so
Travolta leaves him and some other
humans on a mountain to mine for some of
this gold and he's like I'm gonna be
watching you and he sees some drone fly
over and he has like some little thing
that says this is me watching you and
okay I guess I guess he's watching him I
don't know what that means because the
drone flew over and then we get like a
still image I don't get it
this movie should not have been called
Battlefield Earth there's no battling in
this movie it's like the last 10 minutes
of it are battling and this movie's
called Battlefield Earth that should
have been called evil laughter and the
day John Travolta wanted to get noticed
so all of a sudden the humans decide you
know what we're gonna fly to Fort Knox
the safe is open in Fort Knox it's open
and the gold is all perfect perfect it
is pristine
again the safe is open in Fort Knox and
their gold is perfect I don't understand
I did Bill Cosby getting the gold
perfect I was there was go around fully
why is that how oh and I thought John
Travolta was watching them apparently
they were able to fly to Fort Knox and
take some gold and he didn't notice
worst villain ever so they meet up with
the random forest freak people to plan
their revolt again what was with the
intro of those characters they burst out
of the woods wet it your boy you're
pretty cool too hey let's be at a war
together now
in a war I guess they're planning their
revolt and we're supposed to be into it
so the Rainman of man animals is talking
to the forest freaks and his friends and
they're like we need to get to the
radiation bomb storage in Texas how the
fuck these people know what he's talking
about they're monkeys they are always
talking about it it's like yeah the
radiation bomb storage okay okay don't
matter monkeys again what was the point
of giving Johnny all that knowledge at
that knowledge machine it is the dumbest
script writing I've ever encountered in
my life it's like okay we have a dumb
stupid hero and a dumb stupid villain
we'll give him a knowledge machine to
make him smart because that's the only
way we can get him to be a cool enough
hero to do anything he doesn't earn any
of this knowledge he sits there goes Oh
as the machine feeds him knowledge and
apparently all of a sudden he's a really
smart guy and it's so stupid is such a
stupid writing point you don't care at
all about this guy he sat in a chair and
all of a sudden he's a cool badass and
he can do stuff yes the matrix I know
the matrix he plugged into the matrix he
learned kung fu
I know Battlefield Earth just doesn't
understand how to do it right plus in
the matrix you actually see him training
in his mind so it worked so they get
these jets because he knows where Jets
are and of course the jet fuel is
absolutely fine after 1,000 years and of
course all the lights are on in the area
now let me ask you a question where in
the hell is this electricity coming from
it's been a thousand years since
mankind's extinction there's jet fuel
that survives books that aren't rubble
and electricity is still around for us
to harness into light bulbs and of
course Fort Knox is safe was wide open
with all the gold in it so Forest
Whitaker's character is convinced by
Johnny that Travolta has just been using
him this whole time you think and he
tries to blackmail John Travolta's
character apparently John Travolta had
killed the bartender who was the only
other person that Forest Whitaker gave a
copy of John Travolta's security footage
of him being a dick and somehow Travolta
knew that cut off the bartender's head
and placed it in the exact room that
Forest Whitaker would be and when Forest
Whitaker said I know what you're up to
how did that happen he's such a dumb
villainy against somehow teleport and do
all these things it's amazing these
shoots off Forest Whitaker's hand
apparently these people don't feel any
pain so the humans begin to enact their
revolt and of course all the explosives
they have say explosives on it might as
well just say Acme just make it a Looney
Tunes episode already finally the battle
in Battlefield Earth starts and it is a
incredibly slow motion matrix ripoff
shootout that looks exactly like the
lobby shootout scene in the matrix
except without any skill style of any
kind
it just looks horrible now here come the
forest to Ewok monkey people and they're
flying these 1000 year old Jets
yeah they became expert fighter pilots
in seven days so they attempt to blow up
the glass that's surrounding this place
because the aliens can't breathe the air
or they have to do those stupid things
and knows whatever it doesn't break all
the way I just cracks John Travolta's
like kill all men animals shoot it will
do whatever you want
if all you're even letting it to spell
your name in the middle this scene when
some of these humans are dying here in
the background this really muffled voice
go there killer laws I was like so it
actually recorded that and put it in the
movie it was kind of like in the older
spongebob episodes where explosions
would be happening in the background
you'd hear my leg it's exactly like that
so the monkey guy blows himself up with
all of the explosions that he for
whatever reason did not initially use to
blow the dome that just so happened to
be in his ship he kills himself raining
thousands upon thousands of shards of
glass upon everyone humans and cyclos
great plan
so one random guy ops to sacrifice
himself and he teleports himself to the
planet cyclo with a bomb blows up the
planet cyclo instantly somehow Travolta
and Johnny are
like this fighting horrible slow-mo
close-up it's so bad it's like Alex
Cross bad Johnny tricks Travolta into
blowing up his own arm and of course
these people apparently they just don't
feel pain I guess the humans have a
cringe-inducing scene in which they
mourn their losses and then the
girlfriend runs to him in slow motion
and they hug and the music is old
orchestral in the background it's it's
really really bad
so now they've got John Travolta sans
one-armed imprisoned around his gold and
of course it's almost like his entire
characters arc revolves around his
changing laughter so Forest Whitaker
shows up and he's on the human side now
because John Travolta was a dick to him
throughout the whole movie and guess
what he does so what exactly did John
Travolta accomplish with this movie well
he wanted more attention and glory for
himself he didn't get it so he captured
some humans taught them knowledge which
led to them revolting against him and
imprisoning him worst villain ever and
he still couldn't figure out that humans
don't like to eat rat Battlefield Earth
is an incredibly awful movie but as you
watch it you begin to laugh at the fact
that this thing actually exists on earth
this movie was actually made and shown
in theaters around the world this thing
actually happened it is so incredibly
bad in every way there is not one good
thing about this movie not the
production design the script the
directing the acting not even the
musical score is good like even when you
have a bad movie at least a composer can
come in and be like I'm gonna at least
try to make a good score for this movie
but it's just this endless string of
sounds that are meant to in some way
make some of the scenes bearable but it
doesn't just this droning noise
throughout the movie
everything in Battlefield Earth is bad
but it's fun to watch because there
isn't really another movie like this out
there guys I love doing these hilarious
key reviews what did you think of
Battlefield Earth if you saw it
I actually know someone who doesn't hate
this movie so they're out there man
thanks as always for watching guys and
if you liked this review you can click
right here and get stuck menage
[Music]